bonsoir et heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 78 invités vous
entendrez ce soir la responsable de
prélèvement î de France ouest le docteur
Suzanne Vanet nous ferons un point avec
elle sur le don du sang et puis vous
entendrez aussi Jacques Fournier
directeur des itinéraires poétiques sur
la programmation sur la saison
2016-27 mais comme je vous le disais
dans les titres nous recevons ce soir
sur le plateau le docteur Vanet
responsable de prélèvement île-de-fance
dans l'Ouest bonjour Docteur Vanet
bonjour alors quel est l'état des lieux
de du don du sang dans l'Ouest alors
aujourd'hui l'État du sang dans l'Ouest
ben nous avons toujours besoin de de
donneurs ils sont toujours aussi
généreux cependant il faut perdurer
continuer et venir et revenir il faut
savoir quand même que sur une année dans
l'Ouest nous avons besoin d'au moins
55000 prélèvements dans l'année euh et
que pour traiter tous les jours des
patients il faut 1700 produits en
Île-de-France 1700 produits ça se
réparti en en globule en globule rouge
bien sûr mais aussi en placem et en
plaquette euh prélévement que vous savez
être fait non pas sur les collectes
mobiles qu'on voit se déplacer en
île-de-fance mais sur les sites fixes et
donc sur sur le 78 à Poissy et à
Versailles et il y a assez d'information
il faut encore plus informformer les
futurs donneurs je pense que c'est comme
toute chose on a parfois un petit peu
tendance à s'essouffler ou à oublier et
puis euh par rapport à ces ce sang c'est
cette forme de don de sang en site fixe
les gens connaissent pas très bien c'est
une une procédure qui est un petit peu
plus longue euh c'est cette fois c'est
non pas l'établissement du sang qui va
auprès des donneurs mais c'est les
donneurs qui doivent venir dans des
sites puisqu'il faut traiter directement
le sang dans une machine ce qui fait que
ce qui est nécessaire pour le patient
est gardé par la machine et on restitue
le reste qui fait qu'on ne prend que ce
dont on a besoin mais donc ça veut dire
qu'ils ont plutôt pris l'habitude qu'on
vienne chercher leur sang plutôt que
d'aller dans ce type d'établissement bah
apparment probablement d'ailleurs
effectivement c'est c'est ça fait partie
des choses qu'on aimerait comprendre le
pourquoi du comment et c'est pour ça que
certaines enquêtes sont faites par
l'Établissement français du sang pour
savoir les connaître mieux savoir ce qui
fait que ils ont envie de rester de
revenir euh et
donc ça nécessite plus de temps pr
donner son sens son sens total ça dure
une dizaine de minutes plus la collation
le temps d'enregistrement de d'entretien
avec avec la personne qui fait
l'entretien là pour donner son une
partie de son sens c'estàdire soit son
plasma soit ses plaquettes et bien il
faut c'est une procédure qui donne qui
prend de 2h 3h donc c'est du temps plus
c'est pas simplement donner son sens qui
est déjà énorme bien sûr mais c'est
aussi du temps voilà mais quels sont vos
besoins aujourd'hui en Île-de-France il
y en a beaucoup il y a 700 je pense pas
alors en ce moment on est on est en
alerte vous savez que on a des alertes
et on est en alerte orange foncé
c'est-à-dire qu'on fait appel
aujourd'hui et effectivement et en
particulier pour le le les plaquettes
euh on a des difficultés l'Île-de-France
a besoin d'être autonome c'estàdire de
ne pas faire appel au reste à d'autres
régions et actuellement c'est très
limite c'est pour ça qu'on fait appel
vraiment au donneur pour les plaquettes
en particulier plaquettes qu'on peut
avoir aussi par le le don de sang total
on en est extrait mais disons qu'il faut
pour avoir la même quantité de
plaquettes par une procédure qui se fait
en site fixe il faut C donneurs en
équipe mobile pour avoir la même
quantité donc c'est plus compliqué mais
alors quelles sont les craintes est-ce
que c'est véritablement des craintes ou
c'est parce qu'ils ne sont pas au
courant sont pas assez appelés à donner
leur sang probablement un petit peu tout
ça et j'avoue que je ne suis pas en
mesure de vous répondre à ce type de
question précise d'accord ok et
dites-moi aujourd'hui qui peut venir
donner son sang c'est le profil le
profil le profil type tout le monde peut
donner son sang parce que tous les sens
sont intéressants il y a pas tel ou tel
groupe on a besoin de tous les groupes
ça c'est une première chose et pour
enlever certains a prioris les groupes A
B les groupes a les groupes B on a
besoin d'avoir une diversité pour que on
puisse répondre auprès de la diversité
de nos de nos patients de nos malades à
à leurs besoins donc bah le profil type
c'est c'est quelqu'un de jeune jusqu'à
50 exè il a pas d'âge non non non non
disons que on peut donner jusqu'à 70 ans
et pour donner en afféress c'està-dire
que les plaquettes ou les placements
c'est jusqu'à 65 ans il vaut mieux être
en bonne santé et et globalement c'est
surtout l'entretien prèdon qui permettra
de déterminer les possibilités de don ou
pas vous avez dit être en bonne santé
qu'est-ce qu'il peut faire aujourd'hui
qui qu'on prennent pas si on est
diabétique par exemple chosesass
médicaments qui contre-indiquent qui qui
sont qui peuvent donner des
cancers ce genre de choses donc dans le
chez les femmes enceintes ce qu'on
appelle les médicaments thératogènes
ceux-là si on les prend on évite de les
faire passer dans le sang et
éventuellement de pouvoir le transmettre
lors d'une transfusion à une femme
enceinte c'est dans ce sensl hein c'est
pas pour le c'est pas pour le la
personne qui qui prend le médicament euh
et puis bah il faut pas avoir de cancer
faut pas avoir été transfusé il y a
certains pays dans lesquels on il vaut
mieux ne pas avoir été dans les quat
derniers mois d'ailleurs toutes ces
informations vous pouvez euh les
retrouver sur don de sang
euh.efs. sansacent euh.fr euh où euh
tout est bien expliqué et permet
effectivement à chaque personne qui veut
donner d'être d'être plus rapidement
orienté et de pas se faire euh disons
repousser provisoirement euh sur une
collecte et pour vous aujourd'hui
quelles seraient les choses à faire
comment vous pourriez la les les pousser
à venir donner leur sang ben je crois
qu'il faut se projeter on a tous près de
soi des gens qui ont été euh qui ont des
malades de de
de comme des gens qui ont eu des
leucémies des cancers des
hépaties qui ont eu une des
interventions difficiles et je crois que
bah c'est une manière de les aider
encore une fois et on y pense peut-être
sur le moment mais on oublie que en fait
c'est c'est un problème quotidien et
bien je vous remercie docteur Van et
merci de d'être venu sur le plateau avec
nous merci beaucoup tout autre sujet on
passe maintenant à la culture c'est la
reprise des itinéraires poétiques et
notre journaliste Mélanie poquet a fait
un point sur ce qui nous attend avec
Jacques Fournier le directeur pendant la
saison
2016-27 bah la saison elle va être
construite à la manière des précédentes
c'est-à-dire qu'on travaille sur des
partenar
de très nombreux partenariats sur
l'ensemble du territoire de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline d'autant plus
que le territoire c'est c'est largement
élargi ces dernières années donc on a
construit une une saison qui reprend les
grandes thématiques les grandes grands
rendez-vous de l'année la semaine des
écrivains persécuté en novembre et le
Printemps des poètes en mars et on a
intercalé comme à notre habitude des
rendez-vous avec la scène nationale avec
la ferme de BB avec
l'université avec les médiathèques et
tous les part qu'on peut trouver sur ce
territoire nous nous défendons d'abord
et avant tout la parole des poètes tous
ces rendez-vous réguliers pour montrer
que cette parole elle a toujours son
importance et a ils ont toujours quelque
chose à dire surtout sur le monde dans
lequel on vit il semble important de de
de montrer justement ces différentes
facettes ce sera une conférence sur Bert
brcht poête en résistance au mois de
décembre au Théâtre de 5 en yeline ce
sera un atelier d'écriture avec GODF
égal metteur en scène qui qui qui qui
nous évoquera le le nous emmènera dans
l'univers d'André d'ôel ce sera une
conférence sur les poètes américains des
années 60 et 70 ce sera un printemps des
poètes complètement consacré ou
quasiment consacré aux Afriques c'est
dire des poètes de autant du du du
l'Afrique noire que du Maghreb que de
l'Afrique du Sud avec énormément
d'invités qui viennent d'un petit peu
partout du monde entier 2017 sera marqué
aussi par un retour sur les trois
résidences de poètes qu'on avait eu sur
l'année 2016 avec la publication de leur
textes des quatre poètes puisque
j'oublie Claude Bert qui qui qui était
en résidence dans le laboratoire au
l'Atmos la publication des quatre
ouvrages LIVRE et CD d'ailleurs pour
l'un d'entre eux en 2017 et la
représentation publique on espère du
monde là-dessus aussi là on est en train
de préparer la semaine des écrivains
persécutés emprisonnés empêché du 14 au
18 novembre on a trois ou quatre lycées
et collèges de 5ant an divine qui vont
accueillir trois écrivains qui ont connu
la persécution dans leur pays on aura un
poète et journaliste syrien un un un
poète et
romancier turc et un journaliste afghan
voilà ils vont venir rencontrer ces
gens-là c'est la fin de ce 78 invité
merci de nous avoir suivi bonne soirée à
tous